[Applaudissements]
questionnaire de proust
oui c'est le questionnaire pour faire
aux candidates miss france voilà il ya
un américain sur paris première qui
croient que le questionnaire de bernard
pivot
samy naceri ou aimeriez vous vivre aux
caraïbes d'oseille avec les 60 bacon qui
allait gagner voilà prêt aussi à 1,75
s'échelonner sur quatre ans sami votre
idéal de bonheur terrestre on arrête de
me casser les couilles
qu'on laisse faire mon métier tranquille
et qu'on arrête de deux contres
transcrivent les dépêches afp j'espère
crédit j'espère qu'il y en aura pu mais
qu'on retranscrivent les dépêches afp
telles qu'elles sont et que mon avocat
ils soient pas obligés de les appeler de
leur dire ça c'était comme ça et ça
c'était comme ça et pourquoi vous dites
ça et pourquoi il savait ça c'est ça et
que quand j'ai gagné
enlevons les retranscrivent comme quand
on m'a assassiné avec toujours beaucoup
plus petit
pour quelle faute avez-vous le plus
d'indulgence s'est trompé il a voulu
faire bien et s'est gouré quelles
qualités préférez-vous chez l'homme la
mental seriez vous capable de tuer
quelqu'un si on enlève la vie à
quelqu'un que j'aime quelqu'un de ma
famille oui ouais votre vertu préféré
sami
oiseau au hasard console pour un
étudiant le chapeau a dit merci
geneviève il ya quoi sous le chapeau
c'est moi c'est mon truc ça m'excite ce
qui auriez-vous aimé être si vous
n'étiez pas à samy naceri zidane s'est
fait défaut à 18 ans parce que naïf naïf
avec les baffes dans la gueule que j'ai
pris je devienne beaucoup plus de petits
beaucoup plus bas non la chérie de même
fallu une question serait content à
mercy complète en question j'aime bien
parce qu'elle a envie de s'exprimer
la première chose qui vous attire chez
une femme quand ça tombe sur vous j'y
peux rien vous doutez skate dégageant
son visage
sami votre rêve de bonheur avancés avec
mon métier est allé je viens de créer ma
société de production est allé acheter
les droits et continuer à avancer avec
mon frère ce que j'aime et créer les
filmer et monter les films que j'ai
envie de monter
quel serait votre plus grand malheur au
perdant mon fils que durement président
ce que vous détestez par dessus tout et
balance le temps de nature que vous
voudriez avoir je voudrais je voudrais
qu'à un moment donné tout s'arrête
ça va venir tout s'arrête plus tôt avec
tu seras indiqué que moi qui voulais
d'accord tu met sur pause il ya que je
pense qu'il est plus lourde et combien
on peut s'avérer on peut lui faire
regarde personne bull software asie mais
je vais tout sur orne je tenais à la
quincaillerie
ça va commencer c'est une autre vie
maintenant oui c'est un chouette de thor
la savate remplir tes week-end malgré
moi il est à présent votre esprit bien
je suis bien entouré je veux dire j'ai
une jolie femme à côté de moi
la merde geneviève plein de kkr y aller
plein d'or à côté à la tête lui envoyer
mes 10 pour qui lui coûte un bras et
donc tu es bien ouais je suis bien mais
aussi les corrections de ne rien rater
de l'inaptitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux